This lecture is the overview of text
retrieval methods.
In the previous lecture we introduced
the problem of text retrieval.
We explained that the main problem is
to design a ranking function to
rank documents for a query in this
lecture we will give a overview of
different ways of designing this
ranking function.
So the problem is the following.
We have a query that has a sequence of
words and a document that's also
a sequence of words and we hope to define
a function F.
That can compute a score based on the
query and document.
So the main challenge here is to design a
good ranking function that can rank all
the relevant documents on top of all
the non relevant ones.
Now clearly this means our function
must be able to measure the likelihood
that a document d, is relevant to a
query Q.
That also means we have to have some
way to define relevance.
In particular, in order to implement
the program to do that, we have to have
a computational definition of
relevance.
And we achieve this goal by designing a
retrieval model which gives us a
formalization of relevance.
Now, over many decades, researchers
have designed many different kinds of
retrieval models.
And they fall into different
categories.
1st.
One thing many of the models are based
on the similarity idea.
Basically, we assume that if a document
is more similar to the query, then
another document is then we will say
the first document is more relevant
than the second one.
So in this case, the ranking function
is defined as the similarity between
the query and the document.
One well known example in this case is
vectors space model, which we will cover
more in detail later in the lecture.
The second kind of models are called
probabilistic models.
In this family of models we follow a
very different strategy, where we
assume that.
Queries and documents are all observations from
random variables.
And we assume there is a Binary Random
variable called R here.
To indicate whether a document is
relevant to a query.
We then define the score of document
with respect to a query as the
probability that this random variable R
is equal to 1 given a particular
document and query.
There are different cases of such a
general idea.
One is classic probabilistic model.
Another is language model, yet another
is divergent from randomness model.
In the later lecture we will talk more
about one case which is language model.
The third kind of models are based on
probabilistic influence, so here the
idea is to associate uncertainity to
inference rules, and we can then
quantify the probability that we can
show that the query follows from the
document.
Finally, there is also a family of
models that are using axiomatic
thinking.
Here the idea is to define a set of
constraints that we hope.
A good retrieval function.
To satisfy.
So in this case, the problem is to
seek
A good ranking function that can
satisfy all the desired constraints.
Interestingly, although these different
models are based on different thinking.
In the end.
The retrieval function.
Tends to be very similar.
And these functions tend to also
involve similar variables.
So now let's take a look at the common
form of a state of the retrieval model.
And to examine some of the common ideas
used in all these models.
First, these models are all based on
the assumption of using bag of words to
represent text, and we explained this
in the natural language processing
lecture.
Bag of words representation remains the
main representation.
Used in all the search engines.
So with this assumption, the score of a
query, presidential campaign news.
With respect to a document d here would
be based on scores computed based on
each individual word.
And that means the score would depend
on the score of each word.
Such as presidential campaign and news.
Here we can see.
There are three different components,
each corresponding to how well the document
matches each of the query words.
Inside these functions.
We see a number of heuristics used.
So for example, one factor that affects
the.
Function G Here is how many times does
the world presidential occur in the
document.
This is called a term frequency or TF.
We might also denote as c of
presidential and d.
In general, if.
The word occurs more frequently in the
document then the value of this
function would be larger.
Another factor is how long is the
document.
And
This is to use the document
length for scoring.
In general.
If a term occurs in a long document
that many times.
It's not as significant as.
If it occurred the same number of times
in a short document, because in a long
document.
Any term is expected to occur more
frequently.
Finally, there is this factor called
the document frequency.
That is, we also want to look at the
how often presidential occurs in the
entire collection.
And we call this document frequency or
DF of presidential.
And in some other models we might also.
Use a probability.
To characterize this information.
So here is show the probability of
presidential in the collection.
So all these are trying to characterize
the popularity of the term in the
collection in general, matching a rare
term in the collection.
Is contributing more to the overall
score than matching a common term.
So this captures some of the main ideas
used in pretty much all the state of
art retrieval models.
So the natural question is which model
works the best?
Now it turns out that many models work
equally well, so here are a list of the four
major models that are generally
regarded as a state of the art
retrieval models.
Pivoted length normalization.
BM25, query likelihood, PL2.
When optimized, these models tend to
perform similarly.
And this was discussed in detail in
this reference at the end of this
lecture.
Among all these BM25 is probably the
most popular.
It's most likely that this has been
used in virtually all the search engines
and you will also often see this method
discussed in research papers.
And we'll talk more about this method
later in.
Some other letures.
So to summarize.
The main points made in this lecture are
first the design of a good ranking
function.
Pre requires a computational definition
of relevance and we achieve this goal
by designing appropriate retrieval
model.
Second, many models are equally
effective, but we don't have a single
winner yet.
Researchers are still actively working
on this problem.
Trying to find a truly optimal retrieval
model.
Finally, the state of art ranking
functions tend to rely on the following
ideas.
First bag of words representation.
2nd.
TF and document frequency of words,
such information is used in.
the weighting function to determine the
overall contribution of matching a word.
And document lengths.
These are often combined in
interesting ways and we'll discuss how
exactly they are combined to rank
documents in the lectures later.
There are two suggested the additional
readings.
If you have time.
The first is a paper where you can find
a detailed discussion and comparison of
multiple state of the art models.
The second is a book with a chapter
that gives a broad review of different
retrieval models.